So, I've got two questions for you.
What do you think data-bind equals visible hasClickedTooManyTimes really means?
Your possible answers are every time the div is visible, this function will run.
When the user clicks on the div, this is set to true.
Or when this is set to true, the div will be visible.
Only one of those is correct.
Here's your other question.
What do you think the second one,
button data-bind equals click resetClicks will do?
When the user clicks on the button, the resetClicks function will run.
When the user clicks on the button, a reset variable will be set to 0?
Or when the number of clicks is 0, the button is visible.
Once again, only one of these three is correct.
Give it a shot.
What do you think?